[Music]
[Applause]
Peter Schrager NFL Network good morning
football Emmy award-winning show good
morning football Monday through Friday 7
A.M Eastern help me understand this
Peter why why am I I can't get past the
Buffalo game if you didn't have a
concussion why'd you fire the
neurologist yeah there's a lot of
questions and uh we're going through it
and it's like they changed the protocol
overnight and you saw the following week
Bridgewater goes down in the end zone
against the Jets and immediately he's
removed and the same people that were
crying bloody hell about how his two is
allowed to come back to the game were
outraged at Bridgewater was forced to
leave the game so there is this on
ongoing dialogue about the the protocol
and the injuries and then at the end of
the day like
it seems like the fans also want to
watch football at the highest quality so
it's this thin line of like we're you're
back balancing here the reporters they
get into a back he's playing against the
Steelers you got Flores on the other
sideline Stephen Ross is back in there
the 50th Anniversary 50th anniversary of
uh you know the 72 dolphins and it's
like
two is back in Buffalo feels like six
months ago Dan and I think it's just how
the World Turns it's like we're we're
over that let's get on to the next topic
we've got the NFL moves on Page by page
but of course there's a million
questions that have to be answered and
there's a million things that we still
want to know but as an NFL audience I
don't know if anyone really wants to
linger on tua's back injury from week
three no but I just I didn't know we
closed up shop on it and that back
injury is not going to be something that
is you know staying there the rest of
his career anything like that just like
if if I had a back injury and it and it
made me almost stumble fall down twice
and I have to be helped by my teammates
I'd probably get it checked out and
probably figure there might be something
a little bit more to it I I'm sure I'm
I'm just a voice in the wilderness here
I sell us on tonight's game it's it's
Arizona it's New Orleans
go no I'm kidding um
Kyle Brad on our show good morning
football always uses like wrestling
references this is the leader this is
the loser leaves town game
um if the Saints losing their two and
five like it's over and if the Cardinals
are two and five it's not only it's over
then you start thinking like all right
is Kingsbury the guy for this job is is
there is there going to be questions up
top Arizona has lost eight straight
games at home
it's the longest streak they haven't won
since October 24th of last year in their
building and they only have three points
in the first quarter through five games
this season these are horrific stats
stats that show you hey they don't come
ready to play and B that they've got no
home field advantage whatsoever they
walk into that building and it's dead
they're home tonight they're against a
very injured Saints team and DeAndre
Hopkins is back myself for this would be
if Kyler's got any juice if Kings
berries got any juice if there is
anything left in that tank but between
this Duo and this team let it be tonight
and let us see them come back with
DeAndre Hopkins and say all right we got
our guy back and we can roll I don't
have a ton of confidence though that
that's gonna happen do you believe Cliff
Kingsbury
will be the head coach of this team
I don't know next year he signed an
extension but I don't know what the
numbers are and we also don't know like
the background of that extension because
it also was signed in Camden with Steve
Keim the GM and they both were extended
at once and it was like all right you
guys get I can't I'll say right now I
don't know and I think I'm as
plugged in with cliff and those guys as
anybody I don't speak to the owner uh
you know bid will on a daily basis but I
will say this I could see a future where
Cliff is not the Cardinals coach if this
season goes off the rails
give me the number one story so far this
season on the field
on the field the number one story has
been the Resurgence of the New York City
football teams that play in New Jersey I
think the Jets and Giants how
threatening are they no I don't I'm not
I'm not booking any parades down
Broadway yet
um through to get to Halloween and both
these teams are are relevant is such a
big deal for the NFL the NFL hasn't had
a football team in New York City uh the
Giants or the Jets make the playoffs
since the Odell year where they're at
the boat party and that was a first
round exit
um this city is alive I'm in New York
City I guess you could say I'm biased
how I'm saying that's the number one
story but to have the Jets with such
youth be relevant to have the Giants on
this like what felt like a lame duck
year for Daniel Jones and saquon have
this great Resurgence with a new coach I
think it's brought an extra little
lifeblood to this league and it shows
that in any given year you can have the
team that turns it around it just so
happens it's two teams and two
franchises have been the punch line of
the New York Post and the punch line of
football World both doing at the same
time it's pretty cool one is forward two
the other's five and one and no one had
either one of those teams above 500
going into the season Peter Schrager
host of NFL Network's Emmy award-winning
show good morning football also has a
podcast this season with Peter Schrager
podcast launched last week available
wherever you listen to podcast you had
the Jets head coach Robert Sala and Paul
Rudd big Chiefs fan on there uh did
Robert Robert Sala talk about taking
receipts and yeah okay but didn't the
Jets earn that that criticism like how
does he of course how does he say way
over his skis you're kidding he was way
over his skis and I positioned it that
way what are your four and four team
taking receipts of what and he says
openly I mean look there's a million
podcasts there are a thousand needles
and all of them mine's pretty good right
now I feel pretty good salad was awesome
it was candid and he says uh you know
basically I I said it and I immediately
regretted it like I didn't I didn't he
felt it out of his mouth and was like
wait yeah and he's like I wish it didn't
go that way and I wish we were done
talking about that and yet
he thinks the players might have might
have listened and like felt a little bit
of that and I don't that's all
intangible stuff that like hey if he
believes in us maybe we will
the facts are what they are they're
three and on the road they've beaten the
Browns in their building the Steelers in
their building they went to Lambo and
had a 21 year old sauce Gardener who
doesn't know any better wearing a cheese
head around Lambo like
Salah said the receipts line it was
parodied widely here in New York City
and I think he himself knows it was a it
was a regrettable comment and yet in a
weirdest of ways it's going to come back
looking like the gym fossil guarantee
from so many years ago or Mark Messi in
game six yes they've turned it around
ever since yeah
uh the Mac Jones Bailey zappy Patriots
drama who's the offensive coordinator
who's the quarterback do we have a real
quarterback controversy what do you
think maybe Monday they play and there
has not been an announcement on who's
going to go and I think Mac is close to
being healthy
um I'll tell you this if there was a big
gap between Mac and the other uh option
at quarterback whether it was Hoyer or
zappy when he got injured it's much
smaller now
um no one is is talking to Belichick in
a way that they can reveal the true
facts about what it is I'll just say
this from sources around the team and
sources within that building there's a
lot of love for zappy as well as Mac Mac
I would imagine is going to get an
opportunity to get that gig back but I
would think the leash is a lot shorter
um after what zappy has done zappy has
come in and he has played against two
inferior teams the Lions and the Browns
so you have to keep that in mind but he
has not made mistakes and he has you
know right at the ship after it looked
like it was sinking in Mac's last game
so all facts are out there that Bailey
zappy has played objectively better than
Mac Jones was playing the question is
long term is this Mac's job I think he
gets an opportunity to to to bounce back
and we'll see how fired up he is to
regain that that status as the
unquestioned guy in New England I'm just
wondering as the Browns waited for
DeSean Watson if you can just sort of
tread water here maybe be a game over
500 just something that you you know
that when he comes back you're a better
team and and you would think with the
talent that they have there in Cleveland
Peter that wouldn't be asking that much
to just be an average team with that you
know offense and defense here
I mean you lost to the Falcons it lost
to the Jets they're two and four and
then Deshawn Watson has to wait a couple
more weeks to come back but uh what went
wrong in Cleveland it's off the rails
right now and two two terrible losses at
home to the Jets and the Chargers and
then last week yeah you just don't even
show up for this Patriots game and it
feels like okay it's a Lost season and
that was at a point where
I think coming into this year it was
like if they can just hang in there you
know they've got a great running game
and great players on defense but it
looks completely lost the defense is
atrocious and Joe Wood's a defensive
coordinator is a respected guy in this
league so it's a lot of questions and
reset his whole thing was leader doesn't
make mistakes and he's he's been making
a lot of mistakes bad ones uh at first I
was thinking when they were two and one
it was like Hey the Browns they they
could find a way to to get this thing
going and maybe they don't have to rush
to Sean Watson onto the field in week 13
they can let him just start next season
that's not the case uh he's there now
he's starting to practice with that team
and I think that the second he's
available to go he will be inserted
immediately into the lineup and
hopefully this thing is uh not
completely off the rails where it's the
season is a complete loss and a complete
wash because right now they're one of
the the least disciplined and uh I would
say the the the worst defense in the
league four weeks in the last few weeks
uh at what point if you're the Broncos
do you say we can't afford to continue
to let Nathaniel Hackett learn on the
job you're supposed to learn before you
get the job
and the learning curve here is not good
how much patience with this ownership I
don't know I don't know I don't know the
new owners and and George Payton you
know they had a lot of guys he's a GM
they had a lot of guys come through an
interview for that job and he and
Hackett hit it off and you know
O'Connell went in there and they had all
these different other offensive minds
and it was like hackett's the guy and
Roger spoke the world of him and all the
Packers folks loved him and of course he
was with portals and Jacksonville took
him to the AFC Championship game as a
quarterback and then you get here and
it's first year coach
New Market
new quarterback new first year defensive
coordinator defense actually been good
um a lot of new a lot of new faces ever
new owner and this this new owners
didn't hire him they inherited him
and I get nervous because you know you
get a couple then you get a few more and
then it's like sharks are in the water
and if you do that over the course of
the next three months these new owners
they're made of money they've got
billions and billions of dollars Walmart
money and self-made money
um post Walmart stuff and then it's like
well I didn't pick this guy and the
money's not an issue pay him out and
let's start a new one that's a real
possibility always with new owners and
the way it's going it has been uh
unfortunate but you gotta understand
this is the test when you're at your
lowest and you've got rust playing like
this and he might be injured remind me
to know how do you how do you change
things how do you figure it out the Jets
are coming in this week they're the
hottest team as far as like narrative
goes a win with either Russ or Brett
Rippin or whoever would go a long way in
stopping the bleeding especially in the
front of that home crowd if you lose
that game in front of that home crowd
well then when I say sharks are in the
water it's going to get real ugly real
fast so your guests have included Robert
Sala and Paul Rudd who else is uh on the
uh wish list there for your podcast you
know I want to do like coaches that
don't talk during the season I want to
get them to be candid Salah was I want
to get like funny but good so you you're
the best with the celebrities when you
have Sandler and I'm like I'll run to a
TV or whatever and you've got all those
guys what is that dude but I also want
to get like young coaches that the teams
are usually a little protective of I
want to get like young offensive
coordinators young defensive
coordinators young Executives and my
pitch to them is this is a great
platform to not talk about this week's
game and injuries but to introduce
themselves to the audience and so far
we've got a pretty good captive audience
that I'm getting a lot of the uh the
viewers from Good Morning football and
fox that I'm on watching and hopefully
uh some of the listeners to your pocket
to your show can listen to this podcast
just by popping it on it's good go for a
workout listen cook in whatever it is
have it in the background but let's get
to know new people that uh we don't
necessarily know all their names yet
thank you Peter good to talk to you good
luck with the podcast love you man thank
you that's Peter schraker NFL Network
good morning football friend of the show
and uh his podcast this season with
Peter trigger